we're taking the audience to a place
that none of these IMAX films or any
other film has taken audience members to
West Papua is the most diverse
underwater habitat anywhere on earth
it's an underwater paradise that's
unlike any other it's such a special
place
and I think what's amazing too is that
the people have built a way of life to
protect that natural environment they've
found ways to protect their own reefs
it's a pristine underwater environment
and that's why we wanted to make an IMAX
film there we were lucky to find this
great character a young Island boy named
Joey who kind of represents his culture
dedication to keeping the reefs healthy
we follow him on a journey aboard the
cala bia which is a boat that travels
among the island teaching kids about the
importance of their reach we knew that
we could use him with the Cala BIA to
really form the basis of our new IMAX
film journey to the South Pacific his
energy and infectious smile just brings
the film to life we see West Papua
through his eyes
and learning about this amazing place
with him one of the highlights of the
film was our trip to warm on the last
remaining habitat of the Pacific
leatherback turtle and we had another
thrill when we were filming the whale
sharks these are the two largest sea
creatures of their kind and to use IMAX
cameras they use the largest film format
in the world and show them on the world
largest screens audiences are just going
to be blown away so it's our job to try
to capture all of that in a way that
allows the audience member to feel like
he is sharing that experience with us
and IMAX is the only format can do that
the quality of the IMAX 1570 format is
the highest quality that there is bar
none
here at the convergence of two great
oceans schools of anchovies grow in size
when it's time to spawn attracting
hungry predators working with Kate
Blanchet is a dream come true what she
brings to the film will elevate the
movie to a new level
the Cala BIA will take Joey to nine
islands in West Papua I think the
audience is going to love the experience
of having her take you on this ride
and it was so wonderful to come into
these villages where life is just joyful
the shoot we did over in West Papua will
be one of our premiere films the
experience was kind of magical in a way
what we captured there in terms of the
story of these villagers through the
eyes of Joey I think there's a great
deal that audiences can learn and enjoy
that's why I love making these movies
not only are we opening the eyes of the
audience but we're opening our own eyes
I don't really think bringing this
remarkable location to people on the
IMAX screen it's going to be an
experience unlike any other
you